Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the
roundtable of dim lighting,
we're tackling the
issue of self-promotion.
The question is, how do we
feel about self-promotion?
There's a lot of that,
Oh, we never promote ourselves.
We are constantly making stuff
and then you gotta promote it.
And I'm not, you know, I'm
not apologizing for it.
And I would say specifically,
But there is a lot of psychology.
Not just, I mean, we promote
ourselves all the time,
in our own work, in our
own properties, right?
Yeah.
This is, we're not gonna talk about that
as much as we are gonna talk
about when you've got to
go on other people's shows,
make media appearances, have a media day,
and promote yourself.
Yeah, so we're gonna pull back the curtain
on what that's like,
what our experience is,
what our raw assessment of that.
It seems we have a negative view on it
by the tone of our
conversation at this point.
It's definitely mixed
it's definitely mixed.
Because
we're just fresh off our Bleak
Creek Conversations Tour.
And we're just fresh.
We're just fresh.
I mean, look at us.
All black, man.
Look at this, look at these guys.
Where are these guys going?
I'm actually not that fresh,
I'm a little bit jet lagged, you know.
We're recording this on a, what is it?
What day is it, Tuesday?
Tu-tu Tuesday.
I feel better today.
I got back Saturday night.
You don't feel like you
bounced a little bit today?
Nah, no.
You went to the gym this morning, right?
I did not go to the gym.
See, that's it.
Going to the gym bounces you into the day.
I thought about not going
and you shoulda gone.
You shoulda gone man
'cause I'm feeling good right now.
I wanna fight somebody.
I was gonna go yesterday.
Sometimes I get that feeling
I wanna fight somebody.
I'm in that mood right now.
Well, you're not gonna get that from me.
If you start fighting me, I'm
just gonna roll into a ball.
I'm kinda dressed like a boxer, ya know?
Like he's got a hoodie and like a hat.
You're just wearing a hoodie.
Boxer's wear hoodies.
Yeah, they wear hoodies but,
They do things like this.
They wear sweatpants and they jog,
They wear like,
and they jump rope and stuff.
When they come to the weigh in,
they pull their hoodie over their hat.
And sometimes they also have
headphones on like this.
I kinda feel like maybe
I should get into that.
Is it too, is it too late to
get into that Logan Paul thing?
I think that's probably already happened
by the time
I think it happened.
you're hearing this.
When fighters weigh in and
they're wearing headphones,
doesn't that, doesn't
that make 'em weigh more?
Yeah, it's when you wanna
go up to the next level.
Please count my headphones.
No, you come,
That's illegal.
you come to the weigh in like that
and then you strip down into
some colorful underpants.
That's the way I do it at least.
So what I was trying to
say was we are fresh off
the Bleak Creek Conversations Tour.
You know, for the past week
prior to recording this episode,
we've been touring, doing
what you might think
is just a book tour but we
tried to make it really special
and like we had the documentary of us
going back to Buies Creek
and then like making all the connections
of how that ties into Bleak Creek.
And we also released that
on Good Mythical Morning
so we're basking in the
public response to that
which I'm very encouraged by.
Oh yeah.
But again, with the time change
and the being on the
road and a lot of flights
and a lot of self-promotion,
a lot of talking
about yourself in other people's places.
So we're gonna unpack what
that experience is like.
But coming back home to my place,
like it means, it's so important to me.
Yep.
You know?
I just start thinking about,
yeah I wanna be in my bed,
I wanna be on my toilet,
I wanna be on my couch.
I wanna be in my backyard,
I wanna be with my family
and my dog, ya know?
I'd start to thinking about it
and I'd start pining for these things,
especially when in self-promotion mode.
Right.
So we took yesterday off,
we didn't see or talk to each other.
No.
So let's start there.
Let's start with our yesterdays.
I had an interesting yesterday.
Christy had a proposal for me.
I was like, "Hey, let's hang out."
Sent the kids off to school
and she's like, "Let's go get a pedicure,"
I'm like, "Okay."
Interesting.
Anytime you're paying somebody
to like do something to
you, I'm up for that.
You know, a little self pampering.
But what I forgot,
Pedicures suck, man.
I've had a pedicure once.
I don't like people touching my feet.
And it was at the hotel we were staying at
in, I think, like Cabo or something
when Christy and I were down there.
That's the only time I've had one.
And I'd forgotten that
I decided at that time
that I did not like pedicures
and I didn't want another one.
Yep, that's when I decided.
I remembered that when I was
getting this pedicure yesterday.
Here's the thing that I
specifically remembered.
It's not just that, and I agree with you,
I don't like people, I don't
like people touching my feet.
For the longest time, when I got a massage
I would say, "Nix the feet."
I still say that.
I don't want the feet, you know,
there's like some tickling involved
but here's the thing for me.
It brought back traumatic
childhood memories.
I was deathly afraid of
my toenails being clipped.
I certainly wouldn't do it
myself and my mom would,
I would throw what I call a conniption.
I would throw a tantrum and start,
What age are you talking about?
As young as I can remember.
I mean, maybe four or five years old.
But I think, I'm pretty sure it continued
into at least like second
grade, so after I knew you.
I wouldn't let,
My stepdad Jimmy, mom had to call Jimmy
and like grab my ankles
and hold 'em down so that
she could clip my toenails.
Like, I was,
What were you scared of?
I was afraid of being cut
and like bleeding happening.
Man, I am really afraid of
like trimming nails too short.
That, woo, that's like
nails on a chalkboard to me.
That doesn't freak you out?
You ever had a nail cut too short?
Well, yeah.
I mean, I don't look forward to it.
It hurts, it bleeds.
I don't have a phobia,
And what makes it even worse
is that then you have wait
for like, for a week or so
for it to grow out to the point
where it doesn't feel like,
I just start to feel like the whole end
of my finger's gonna start nubbin' off.
I got nail problems.
I mean, you see what's
happening there on those.
See that, see how it detaches?
Yeah, you gotta lot of white, white ends
but it's not like a french manicure.
It's psoriasis.
See, you get psoriasis
under your nail beds
and the nail detaches.
So this will go all the way down sometimes
and then it'll just go,
Is that from, I thought you
determined that was from diet?
No, no, I've talked about it.
I thought your diet would fix it.
Well, my diet causes it
to not be nearly as bad
but yeah, I still have flare-ups.
There's none on this hand right now.
But you can see,
Do you have it on your toenails too?
Not as much on my
toenails but you can see,
if I were to cut that down,
that nail down to where it needs to be,
there's a lot of like fleshy part.
That's a normal, this is
a normal person's nail.
Yeah, like the nail.
The nail goes to the end of the finger.
Yeah, that's great.
But that doesn't happen on
any of my fingers anymore
except that index finger
because I've got nail problems.
Well, I'm in there and it's like,
I had to start like doing some
deep breathing techniques.
I didn't want to complain
or like bolt out of there.
I was like, maybe this is
like therapeutic for me,
like facing my fears.
That's not what the
pedicure's about though.
I mean, I appreciate you
Well, it was for me.
trying to change
I made it
change your perspective.
about that for me.
But you're supposed to enjoy it.
I'm doing some like deep belly breathing
and then on my big toe, apparently she,
I wouldn't say I have an ingrown toenail.
But she did.
It kind of goes in on the side
and I had cut the thing a little too short
so then she's like digging in there,
like trying to do some sort of operation
and I'm like, oh gosh this is horrible.
Does your wife enjoy it or
does she enjoy the results?
I think she enjoys it.
Some people don't mind
There was a little bit of a leg massage.
their feet being touched.
I got over that.
I don't enjoy, like, the foot massage part
of a massage just makes me laugh.
I cannot just enjoy it.
It feels, it either
feels like it's ticklish
or it just feels incredibly uncomfortable
but there's no, it doesn't
feel soothing in any way.
And trying not to laugh
makes it more uncomfortable, right?
'Cause then you're kinda like squirming.
'Cause you don't wanna laugh.
Like, why not just come out and laugh?
Because laughter's a nice release.
Because then you just seem like the Joker.
You don't wanna do that, just
laughing at awkward times.
Well, no, I think they would understand
that like, hey, it's ticklish.
They've encountered a
ticklish person before?
Yeah, so it's not like they would think
you're demented or something.
How do your toes look though?
How do your nails look, great?
Uh, good.
They weren't painted or anything.
I would definitely, if I'm gonna take
that much time for something,
it's definitely gotta
be a massage next time.
It can't be the pedicure.
Yeah.
But I think there are people
who like they never let
anybody touch their toes.
I said that backwards.
They never touch their toes themselves,
they only let other people do it.
So it's just like, "Oh,
I don't trim my nails.
"Somebody does that for me."
You think that's true?
Uh,
I think that's gotta be the case.
Yeah, I'd say a lot of people.
Rich ladies.
Yeah.
Rich ladies don't touch their toenails.
They let other people do it.
It's hard to get down there
and like really give
it a detailed working.
Um, I didn't get a pedicure yesterday.
What'd you get?
Manicure?
A manicure, yeah.
You know, I did think
about getting a manicure.
I'm not gonna let any,
I mean what are people gonna do with that.
There's nothing, there's
nothing they can do.
Oh, they could do a lot.
Shine it up.
Trim it down.
But,
Tame, tame those cuticles.
The unfortunate thing is that
both of my kids were sick
and had to stay home from school.
Ooh.
And so then Jessie was like,
"Well, I mean I feel like we
should stay here with 'em"
and I'm like, "I feel like we should
leave them to themselves."
Dad got a day off,
he was thinking he was going to get
to have a day date with his wife,
Yeah.
and so I still wanted that to happen.
Sure.
And she was like, "Well,
what are they gonna eat?"
I was like, "Well, there's a kitchen."
You know, there's a kitchen
there, there's food in there.
How sick were they?
Were they like bed-ridden or
they were just like sniffles?
They were like, it was a cold
and maybe a little bit
of a fever for Shepherd,
so it was like ah, this
wouldn't be responsible,
this would be irresponsible
to let them go,
To school, yeah.
So did you leave 'em?
Yeah, we left 'em.
Did you win?
Yeah and then Jessie,
And when you came back,
were they all right?
They were still there.
Yeah, so, good choice.
I mean, Jessie would say things like,
she told 'em, she said,
"Okay, there's some pasta,
"there's some pasta in the
refrigerator that you can",
like some ravioli-type thing, you know?
Okay.
It's in the fancy Italian section of the,
I call it the fancy Italian section
of the frozen, of the cold
part of the grocery store
where it's like the
pasta that isn't frozen,
it's in that plastic thing
Oh yeah.
And you can throw it
in there and boil it up
then you feel a little
bit more like a chef.
All you did was boil some pasta.
But it was never frozen, so it's fresh.
Yeah it was never frozen
so it feels fancy.
Yeah.
It feels kinda like the
Italian food version
of a pedicure.
Yeah, so you're just
throwing that at the kids.
Well, they can make that.
Locke can boil that
and then Jessie's like,
"Well, what if he doesn't
turn the stove off?"
I'm like, "Well, it'll just be, you know,
"it'll be a stove that is on."
Because stove's can be on, right?
How long a stove is on
doesn't necessarily
increase the danger, right?
But the burner could be off
but the gas could still be on.
Then you gotta problem.
That's a problem but
that's kinda hard to do.
Yeah.
But I did text Locke and said,
"Hey man, if you turn the stove on,
"make sure you turn it off,"
and he was like, "Okay."
And when you got home, what was burned?
Nothing.
Nothing was burned.
That's good.
They had full bellies and,
But what did you do?
I went to a restaurant.
Okay.
Had a brunch-ish thing.
Had a brunch.
And then we went grocery shopping.
Oh yeah.
Now we're to it.
Yeah.
Romance.
I mean, I could spend a
lotta time in Whole Foods.
Really?
Yeah.
Yeah, Whole Foods is kinda like,
there is a sense of
discovery when you go there.
Yeah.
Unless you go there a lot.
I don't.
I don't, I don't go there a lot.
Yeah, so it's kinda like, whoa,
they got this fancy, they
gotta lot of fancy crap.
Well,
And then it's like,
I wanted to come home and I
wanted to grill something.
Okay.
And they just have, the meat section
is just so impressive.
The meat section?
Have you seen the meat section
No.
in Whole Foods?
I mean, it puts other
meat sections to shame.
I'm more of a like the weird beverage.
They got weird beverages, yeah.
And peanut butter spread sections.
They got that too.
What did you get?
Chicken thighs.
That doesn't seem odd.
No.
Doesn't seem very,
There was a lot of things
that I could've gotten
that I couldn't have gotten anywhere else.
Like they had a giant, just
a giant tomahawk steak.
Oh yeah.
Just I mean,
That's kind of intimidating.
Just obscene.
Like I don't even know if
it would fit on my grill.
And don't wanna mess that up.
And um,
You can't go wrong with chicken thighs.
But I do wanna get one
of those at one point.
Daddy cooks a tomahawk
and then I just come in,
holding it by the bone and
let the family eat off of it
like a giant meat drumstick.
So then, you could rent like a cave.
You could like all go into a cave,
No, I wanna do it in the kitchen.
You could wear like skins.
You could show up with a big hunk of meat.
And but no, I got chicken thighs.
Man, chicken thighs.
Can't beat a good chicken
thigh on the grill, man.
I put some rub on 'em.
Boneless?
Skinless?
No, I went bone in, skin on.
Oh yeah.
Even though I talked
about getting boneless
but Jessie was like, "No, no,
you gotta get the bone in"
and I understand why.
It's just a little, it's
a little nastier to eat
'cause of the dark meat and you get down
right next to the bone and no
matter how well you cooked it,
it's a little pink right next to the bone
and you're kinda like,
"Did I cook this enough?"
Oh.
And you're asking yourself that question.
But no, I put some rub on 'em
and then I cooked 'em on
some hot coals, charcoal,
then I put some barbecue
sauce on at the end
and let it caramelize a little bit,
you know, blacken 'em up a little bit.
Um hm.
Also grilled some poblano peppers,
Oh!
along with them.
The California ones.
Fire-roasted poblanos.
Cut those up, put in
the middle of the table.
You could have 'em
along with your chicken.
Everybody was happy with dad,
at least for a little bit.
Okay, that's good.
But your toes though.
I mean, my toes were in shoes
the whole time, nobody saw,
I think your toes need work.
I've seen 'em occasionally, those nails,
I mean I think you
really stand to benefit.
It's not a,
It needs to be done.
No, it's not a lack of care.
I--
It has nothing to do
with care, it's genetics.
Yeah.
I could get,
They can buff it and shape
it, they can do something.
I don't know why.
For who?
Who would it be for?
You?
'Cause it's not for me.
I don't care.
I feel like the way your nails grow,
they like grow up and out.
No, they grow, they
hug the end of the toe.
They don't grow out, they
just go around the toes.
That's good.
Maybe you never need to cut 'em then.
Like a claw.
It's like your toes have a helmet
if you let it keep growing.
A little nail helmet.
I keep 'em trimmed, for the most part.
It's just,
That's a real long ways for you.
They're just unsightly.
To get down there to that toe.
I don't, to be honest with you,
and this is probably sexist.
I just don't trust a man
with good-lookin' feet.
Hm.
You know, I just, I feel
like he's up to something.
That explains why whenever
we have an important meeting
or interview you ask people
to take off their shoes and socks.
Right.
And if it's a man and he
has like spectacular feet,
I'm like, "You know, I don't know.
"I don't know if I can trust you."
Yeah, that's probably sexist.
It's probably multiple things.
I'm just being honest.
Speaking of being
honest, I wanna be honest
about what it's like to
do the self-promotion
so we're gonna get into that.
Well, I think on the calendar
we called it media day.
The day in particular,
we did a number of things
but the day that I am
thinking about in particular
is Monday of this past week
when were recording this,
in which we had to
In New York City.
We had to get up.
I'm just gonna give like
an overview of the day
and then we can get into the details.
Okay.
We had to get up, get dressed,
go to The Today Show first?
I think so, yeah.
Then we had to go to Conde Nast,
who owns Wired and Vanity Fair,
do three videos with them,
and then immediately go
to The Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon.
And then go directly from The
Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon
to The Bleak Creek Conversations
and that's why we showed up
at that particular show in our suits.
When I say it like that,
it doesn't feel like
it was a whole lot but it certainly felt
like a whole lot at the time.
Well, especially with the time change.
I mean, it's three hours difference
so you're having to get up,
let's just say three hours earlier
than we normally would.
I definitely had not yet adjusted yet.
So that's kinda, and it
was the second or third day
of having been on the time, you know,
that's when the jet lag really hits.
So it was pretty difficult
but I mean, you go on the Today Show.
With all these, with the television shows,
it's true of Fallon, it's
true of the Today Show,
and any other appearance like that,
you do this pre-interview
where you're kinda talking
to the producer in order to, you know,
they know what you wanna promote.
It's like we're talking
to them about the novel
so that they can find a touch point
that works with their audience
so they can ask us a question
that then we can say
something that'll resonate.
But then you also, you gotta try
to get a funny story in
there or like play a game.
Apparently, you know, they're
throwing more and more things
at guest appearances in order
to get people to watch them.
We can unpack that more
but I think when we went
to the Today Show and The Tonight Show,
it's like we kinda knew based on
the pre-interview with the producers
what it is we were gonna be doing.
But I will say that that interview went,
it was very short, but it went a lot,
it actually wasn't what we had been asked
in the pre-interview, unlike Fallon,
which we can get into in a second.
Well, let's back up a little bit
and talk about thinking
about what we were gonna wear
because
Okay .
that was the first thing that happened.
All right, we have this wonderful stylist,
Kimmy Erin, who is the person
who helps us figure out
what we're gonna wear when
make these media appearances.
If you think that we looked
good on Jimmy Fallon,
you can thank Kimmy Erin.
Um hm.
And she also put together these looks
for the Today Show and then
We had another day
of stuff we needed to do.
A Chicago thing, yeah.
So I think that we have
this, we've discussed this,
we're comfortable in two
different modes typically,
when it comes to what we're
wearing, and that is casual
Whatever we would wear
on Good Mythical Morning.
Which is whatever we would wear on GMM.
Which is basically what
we would wear, you know,
if I was just getting up
and going about my day.
Right.
And then we have very
dressed up, sharply dressed
like we were on Fallon.
Full suit, tie, socks that match, etc.
I like to wear, it's fun to get dressed up
every now and again,
especially when it's something
that's important to us that you can
be justified getting that fancy.
Like being on the Tonight Show
And a lot of people
A lot of people take a different tack
when they go on the Tonight Show.
Saw Tyler Ninja.
He went on the Tonight Show in a hoodie.
He was dressed like I am right now.
Like a boxer getting ready to weigh in.
Let's say a gamer.
Yeah.
He was dressed like a gamer.
And so he was like,
and everybody does a different thing.
We're like, "Nah," I said,
"we're gonna dress up."
But there's this what you
might call a no man's land
for us which is this, would
you call it business casual?
It's called the way we
looked on the Today Show.
So I had this like black
jacket over a turtleneck
and these tan pants and these black shoes.
I would very rarely if ever choose
to wear any of these
things for myself, right?
I mean, I thought you looked good in it.
I mean, the pants that
I wore were purple pants
from a suit that I had but
then I had this sweater,
this like thin, very dressy,
block pattern sweater
that I wore with it.
I thought yours was a little less.
I actually would, I would
wear that like on a nice date.
But not really, not in L.A.
There's very few places where
Yeah.
you'd go on a nice date.
Like you don't go out,
at least I don't like go
out for a date in L.A.,
even at a really nice restaurant,
and like wear a blazer.
Yeah.
I don't just like put
a blazer on over stuff.
That weird in between stage,
I just can't find a way to be comfortable.
But for the Today Show,
we were given that.
We were given something
in this middle zone,
the things that we ended up wearing.
And we had a choice.
I will say that we have a choice.
So Kimmy comes in, she has a spread
of different clothes,
and so she's going for
this sort of updated, I
would say elevated casual,
little bit dressed up but
little bit dressed down look
for the Today Show, because if you look
at what people wear on the Today Show,
that's what they wear.
And so and also you're thinking about,
it's funny because we have conversations
with our publisher who says things like,
"You know, mostly moms
are gonna be watching
"the Today Show at the hour
that you're going to be on,
"the fourth hour of the Today Show,
"and so we want you to impress moms."
Right.
"And say something about the book
"that would make them want to buy the book
"for their teenager."
So then we picked out these outfits
that we just described to you
and then we packed 'em
and then we're like,
we're talking on the
flight and we're like,
"Man, that's", we're like
fretting about these outfits.
We're like, "Man, I just don't,
"I just don't feel comfortable".
And I'm saying things like,
"You know, you're jacket's so big.
"You're already so big.
"You make me look small.
"Why you gotta wear this big-ass jacket
"that makes me look even smaller?"
And so like that's my
qualm and you're like,
"Well, I'm not even comfortable
wearing this anyway."
We don't have to talk about that
but I think that's in your mind.
It is, yeah, it was my
overthinking of the ensemble.
But you're like, "I don't
even want to wear this anyway.
"I don't feel like, it's not us,
"I don't feel it's comfortable."
It's like all the stuff
that you just said.
And so then we tell Jenna.
We're like, "So, we're
thinking about not wearing
"the clothes that Kimmy picked out.
"We're thinking about wearing
the slightly less dressy
clothes that she picked out
for the Chicago thing on the Today Show.
Yeah.
So she's like, "Okay,
I'll get those ready"
and then we get a text from Stevie
and Stevie's like, "So I
heard you guys are thinking
"about not wearing the
clothes that Kimmy picked out
"for you for the Today Show."
That was like uh-oh, here we go.
'Cause I could tell.
Now this is, obviously we have
an incredible relationship
with Stevie and we've
been working with her for,
how many years has it been?
Seven or eight years.
And this is often the
nature of our relationship.
This is what we want her to do.
In fact, when you wished her
a happy birthday the other
day, you said thank you
for supporting us,
Disagreeing.
disagreeing with us and blankety-blank.
Because she's very good at what she does
and she's usually right.
And so, she was like, "Well,
I do think that you do want
"this to be an elevated look,
"you are trying to impress
moms and I think that,"
and she likes sends us the pictures,
because once you get
through in the wardrobe
you take a picture of yourself,
she's like, "This is what
you're thinking about wearing
"but this is what you could be wearing.
"I think you should go with
what you could be wearing."
And I'm like, she's probably right
but I just want to be comfortable
and does it really matter anyway?
Who's gonna watch this?
I started thinking things like this.
I'm like, is going on
this show and talking
about this book for 45 seconds
gonna make anybody buy it anyway?
That's the kinda thing I started thinking.
It's easy to start thinking that,
especially when you start doing it.
But yeah, I'm like, listen, okay,
we 're not gonna die on this hill.
Like Jenna brought these clothes.
But then Jenna, so we had
that conversation with Stevie
and I was like, "Okay, we'll
keep talking about it."
Neither of us made a definitive decision.
You got off of the text thread.
I think you went to work out or something.
You were like, "I'm not
gonna talk about this now".
Yeah.
So after some back and forth with Stevie,
then I text Jenna.
I'm like, "Okay, well we
may wear the other clothes."
And she was like, "I
thought you might say that
"and I've already got them ready."
And then
Yeah, she knows what's up.
And then she was like, 'I agree that
"that's what you should wear."
So okay, Jenna and Stevie now both think
that this is what we should be wearing
to impress all the mom's
watching the Today Show
in the fourth hour and
so that's what we did.
We wore it.
You know,
and it's all a game.
So looking at this as like a case study,
there's two different
ways you can look at this
as a listener, I'm thinking.
One is yeah, this is a game
and maybe you can see how it gets,
it can start to wear on you,
'cause it's like, no pun intended,
okay, I'm wearing something
that I wouldn't naturally
wear, even on a date,
but I'm doing it so that I can reach
this perceived mom demographic.
It's like eh.
But then, on the other hand it's like,
you've got somebody who's bringing in
like a spread of clothes
and we just go in, you know,
we're trying all this stuff on
and somebody makes us look elevated.
Isn't that fun, you know?
And I mean it's definitely
fun to, and it is.
I think both are true, ya know?
Especially when you talk about the suits
and like being able to
like look your finest
and go on the Tonight
Show for not the first
but I think the sixth time?
Yeah.
Ya know, that's frickin' awesome.
So it's like.
No, it's great.
We're not complaining.
It's just we think it's amusing,
the games that you have to play
when it comes to marketing, you know?
Well, I will say that in the moment,
in the moment it is
difficult for me to enjoy.
Yeah.
I am often, when that day,
so I knew that day was coming, right?
And I was like, okay, we're
gonna do the Today Show.
By the way, for those of
you who might be confused,
if you were following along
during the week that we,
we'd recorded the Today Show
but then it shot, it aired
that Thursday or Friday so,
but all this was done on the same day.
I was thinking about that day
and we have so little
control in those situations.
So like for every situation
that we were going into,
we're not in control.
We're not hosting, we're
on somebody else's show.
Um hm.
And I definitely don't look forward to it.
I actually start thinking about,
I had these fantasies about
being in my hotel room
at the end of the night, going to bed.
Yep.
That is not necessarily a
healthy way to see that day
when you wake up in the morning
and you're thinking about, ah,
I just wanna be back here going to bed
because I'm anxious about
the stuff that I have to do.
And I don't want to over blow it,
it's not a debilitating,
it's not like a true,
it's not like a anxiety disorder.
I'm not like super uncomfortable,
it's just I have trouble
getting myself to enjoy this.
I'd rather be doing this
on my own terms, ya know.
But then, in the moment,
especially depending on what it was,
I think when we were on Fallon
and we were performing a
song that we had written
when we were 14, I was
legitimately having a good time,
Yeah.
at that point.
Yeah, that was amazing.
But for the Today Show,
I mean, the morning shows are like zoos.
I mean, it's just like
with all cages open.
It's just everybody's going
everywhere in cramped quarters
and you're being shoved here to wait
and then come out here and
then, oh, let's meet the host
and oh, there putting blindfolds on you
and you're eating a
sandwich that they made .
It's like, we knew we were gonna do that
and that was funny.
And then we did the interview
and it was we knew we were gonna get
a couple of questions about the book.
We get the first question,
'cause we wanna talk to
the moms about the novel.
You know, we got all
dressed up for you, mom.
You wanna hear about this novel?
And so they ask you,
"What's the novel about?",
and you're like sharing
what the novel's about.
And then I'm like, okay, I
know what my follow up is,
just to kind of clarify
what I think's gonna
resonate with the viewer.
But I didn't even have a chance
to get that in because
they move so quickly,
you're giving your answer
about the brief synopsis
of "The Lost Causes of Bleak Creek"
and right on the heels of that she says,
"You guys wanna play a
game where we zoom in
on food and you guess what it is?"
I was like, "Whoa, okay, sure!
So you know, I've heard
Joe Rogan talk about this.
It's like being in a rock tumbler.
Joe Rogan has talked about the fact that,
he's like, "I hate doing morning radio
"and I don't wanna do
appearances and interviews
"so I just have this podcast
and I just tell people
"that I'm gonna be somewhere and they come
"to my shows and they sell out
because", and you know what?
He can do that because he has
the most popular podcast in the world.
We can't do that.
If we just told you guys
on GMM and Ear Biscuits
about what we were doing,
a lot less people would find out about it,
so we don't have the privilege
of being able to make that
but I understand the impulse
because even the way
podcasting in general.
I mean obviously we don't
do interviews anymore
but the way that everything is put
into these really bite-sized pieces.
Even when you've got a daily
show like the Today Show,
which I guess goes for, is
it four hours every day?
I don't know, it's at
least four hours every day.
Well, at least three but go ahead.
'Cause we were in the fourth,
they say we were in the fourth hour
so it's gotta be at
least four hours, right?
Yeah, that's when they don't
worry about the news anymore
and they start zooming in on pictures of
Right,
and so
food.
if you have got to talk
and fill that time every single day,
you would think this might be a place
for a slightly slower
paced, relaxed conversation
about something but no, even
in that, four hours of content,
it's gonna be, "What's your book about?"
You say one line and you say,
"All right, let's play a game
where we zoom in on food."
Um hm.
That's just the nature of the medium.
I'm not necessarily complaining about it
but I'm just saying, you have to know that
that is the environment you're going into
as opposed to when we made the appearance
on the Dead Meat podcast
and Pete Holmes' podcast.
Yeah.
And the Books On The Subway podcast,
which we did in New York.
Basically any podcast.
Any podcast.
Any podcast you can be like,
I'm gonna talk about this at my own pace
and I'm gonna get to say the things
that I wanna say about it.
Which by the way, if
you're, I do recommend you
listening to those podcasts.
If you're reading the novel right now
and you're into the details of it
but you want a spoiler-free conversation,
Dead Meat James podcast, Dead Meat podcast
was a really fun discussion.
Yeah, with James and Chelsea.
And then similarly, spoiler-free
podcast conversation
on Books On A Subway, like a
off the rails conversation.
That one went places.
So yeah.
And then particularly for,
You Made It Weird with Pete Holmes,
two hours of talking about
a lot of topics that,
and you know using the book
as a jumping off point,
we talked about lots of
things in the realm of faith
that I don't think we've ever talked about
so if you're interested in that,
definitely check out our
guest thing on Pete's podcast.
But yeah, when it comes to podcasting
and that pacing, podcasting gives me hope
because it is that conversational,
drawn out, go in deep.
I mean, what we're doing
right now is rewarding.
It's a rewarding experience for us
and I'm just glad that
people wanna listen,
Well, I think there's also an authenticity
to the platform, not just given the fact
But you could've dressed
a little more elevated, I'm just saying.
Exactly.
So it's like, why are we
worrying about this pretense?
As you listen to us talk
about this, I'm sure,
because you've chosen
to listen to a podcast,
you've chosen to make guys
who make primarily internet videos a part
of your entertainment landscape.
If you've made that decision,
then you probably have chosen that
because you have a distaste
for the traditional way things are done.
You're not watching the Today Show.
You don't wanna see
these prepackaged clips
that are moving at this ridiculous pace.
You don't wanna think about, oh those guys
are dressed like that, not
because it's who they are
but it's who they think
someone else wants them to be.
I understand that that
might be a huge turn off.
We're just kind of being really honest
about the way that we're talking about it
because it is a game.
When you go into someone else's territory
and your, the whole point is to be there
to appeal to their
audience so, very frankly,
you can sell more books
because you believe
in what you created and you wanna be able
to write more and you want this thing
to break outside of your fan base,
you kinda have to swallow
some of those things.
Well, you don't have to
but we have chosen to,
without any shame, to
swallow some of those things.
But I would say that it
is the more laid back,
more authentic, new media
appearances that are more fun.
But you know, the
traditional television media,
you see how they're being
informed by the internet.
It's like your point about the Today Show
was you'd think that by the fourth hour
that they could stretch things out
and get a little more conversational.
Obviously that's not the case
because we're sitting there like, quickly,
I mean our segment was so
short, even in the fourth hour.
And we did so many things.
If you don't stop
and zoom in on food,
somebody's gonna turn it
to Good Morning America.
Apparently.
Right, is that the theory?
Well, it really kinda mirrors
what's happening online
in terms of click bait.
Or I'll say the way that
even the Tonight Show
and all the talk shows
have to create content
that then works on the internet, you know?
I mean, we found ourselves in situations
that were not that different
than Good Mythical Morning because of how
the landscape is changing.
Perfect example, the next
day we flew to Chicago
and we were on the Windy City,
I think is the name of
the show, it's like,
I think it's the ABC affiliate.
Yeah, the Chicago
In Chicago.
version of the Today Show, basically,
or Good Morning America.
And you know,
I think that's actually airing today
that we're recording this.
We never sat down and had an interview.
We said a couple things about the novel,
they held it up, they plugged it,
but we played this game.
What do they call it?
I don't know but it was Feel
and Squeal, it was what we do
Put your hand in a box
and then you guess what
it is your feeling.
Now the night before, on the Tonight Show,
the guest before us was Reese Witherspoon
and when she first came out,
she put her hand in a box
and tried to figure out
what it is she was feeling.
She played Feel and Squeal.
Now I'm not saying that the Tonight Show
and the Windy City have copied
us in something we invented.
I don't even know if we invented it.
I know that there was
I know another,
it was an idea that was waiting to happen.
Vanity Fair did something
called the Fear Box
and it was very much the same thing
we were doing with Feel and Squeal but,
and who cares if it was before or after?
It's an obvious idea
once you start thinking
of let's have guests do things.
But that's what everybody's doing now.
It's like you find yourself
in Chicago on a morning show
and they're playing the same thing
that Fallon's playing, the
same thing that we're playing.
And not to mention on the Today Show,
the whole zooming in on something
and guessing what it is,
well, we've done that as well.
Again, this isn't a, hey we did it first.
We're not saying we did it first
but we make a show that is
the pieces of the traditional shows
that are designed to then be viral
or to break out or to
make it seem more fun,
well, we have a show
that is built primarily
with those sensational things
in Good Mythical Morning.
And so the conversation
that we started having,
Yeah.
was, and again, we talk
about this all the time.
While we're traveling
and while we're supposed
to be enjoying, hey, we
gotta book that's out
and people are responding well to it
and we get to go on the Today Show
and we get to go on Fallon.
We just continue, it's our
mode to just continue to work
and to discuss and to figure
out, what are we gonna do next?
I actually have more fun
doing that than not doing it
so it's fine but what we kept saying was,
hmm, you know we're constantly trying
to innovate in lots of different ways
but also within Good Mythical Morning,
and it's just like when you go to a,
for lack of a better word, a
local news show in Chicago,
and they're doing the thing
that you do on your show,
it's kinda like when
your mom got on Facebook
and you were like, I don't think
Facebook is for me anymore.
The thing that we started thinking is,
all right, we gotta do something else.
Now that they're doing it for the moms,
now we gotta do something new that they,
they can copy that if they want
but I kinda feel like
the pressure to be like,
all right, this has gotten
all the way to this point.
Let's find something else.
Which is a conversation
we're constantly having.
We're constantly trying
to invent new things but
Especially towards the end of a year
when we're starting to think strategically
about what 2020 looks like.
We're just scratching the
surface of that conversation.
Yep.
But when it comes to
Good Mythical Morning,
it's like as we talked about
with Ear Biscuits, evolve or die.
And we don't have the answers
and so I actually, I'm at a
pretty unsettled point because,
Unsettled.
I think we've started,
Even with a fresh pedicure,
you're still unsettled.
Uh yeah, sadly.
Interesting.
Because I think we've
identified this challenge
and we said, you know
you read the tea leaves
in the Windy City show and
it's like, if they're doing
what we're doing, then we need
to be doing something else.
So it's like,
Hundred percent.
So it's like not knowing what that is
and absolutely knowing that it's not
a big, drastic change that
happens overnight, you know,
the way that everything's set up,
the way that we produce
Good Mythical Morning,
it's more like how do
we continue to evolve?
Not how do we drastically
change what the show is.
But even within that evolution,
like knowing strategically
what's the long view.
Identifying the problem but
then not yet having the answers
to me is an unsettling
point and I think I feel
a little bit more engaged in
the challenge of it right now
than I have over the
past few years, I think,
when it comes to Good Mythical Morning.
Yeah, I agree with that.
And it's by no means
not the only challenge
that we're facing.
I mean, creatively there's lot of things
we're trying to figure out.
I think it was interesting
that we've been having this
conversation about innovation
and then we go and basically
every single appearance that we make.
Also, let's talk about the fact that we,
I don't know when those
videos are gonna come out,
the ones that we shot for Vanity Fair, but
Well, just talk about
'em, it doesn't matter.
We did a lie detector thing, right?
Well, we've already done
a lie detector thing.
We've done a lie detector
thing on our our show
and we've also done it
With our moms but that's not
what you're talking about.
But we've done a lie
detector thing for BuzzFeed,
I think, like two years ago, right?
And now we're doing
another lie detector thing
with whatever outlet that was.
Vanity Fair.
And so I think it's a funny video
but you start to get this sense
that everyone is doing
the same, they're seeing,
they're looking out,
they're seeing what works,
and then they're trying to do it.
Some people just do it exactly the way
that they've seen it done.
And it works.
Yeah.
Until it stops working
and so I think we have
to be the ones to find the next things
that we're gonna try that
other people will emulate.
Well, and it's a tall order.
We have an incredible team
and they're coming up
with things all the time.
When I say we, I mean all of us as a team.
I'm not just talking about the two of us.
But I'm just saying that it's,
the question that is in my mind right now
and I don't know if I'm going to be able
to articulate this way
in a way that makes sense
to even me or anyone else.
Try it in Spanish.
Meh, that would be even harder.
That would be .
Okay, you've proven your point.
Hold on, think I just,
That was French and Spanish.
Yeah okay.
is what you just did.
Right, yeah, yeah.
Well, France and Spain
I didn't mean to derail you.
are close to each other.
You said you didn't know
There are some people who
probably speak frenish
and I just did it.
You said you didn't know
if you could articulate your point,
and then I made it even
more difficult, I'm sorry.
Well, you specialize in that.
Oh gosh.
Pedicures and derailing.
But the,
It would of been funny if
you'd have just ignored it
when I said Spanish.
I don't know if
to me it feels like it's not
just finding the next box
to stick your hand in, right?
What's the next version of
a box to stick your hand in?
A box to stick your foot in?
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
You can get really close to it
but really what we're talking about,
we're talking about a genre.
We're not talking,
Yes.
There's evolution within a genre
and then there's the genre of,
there's an evolution of the genre.
Evolution within the genre
or evolution of the genre.
Right, 'cause how,
And you,
'Cause you talk about food,
you talk about us eating
some much food on our show.
You can find different
ways to, no pun intended,
slice it.
That's a genre.
And you know, well, let's eat things
from different places.
I specifically remember,
we still do come up
with some ideas, I specifically remember
when the international food thing was
Birthed?
Birthed or pitched to us and it was like,
"Hey, we're gonna play a game
where you guys eat something
"from international fast food
location around the world
"and then you have to guess
what country it comes from."
And then I was like,
"Can we make it physical?
"Like, what if we had a map
and we threw darts at it
and that was the way that you guessed?"
And that became a format that
no one else is doing, right?
And then the shuffleboard
thing, it was an answer to,
"Hey, let's guess when things came from
"and what's a fun way
to interact physically
"with the timeline?"
And somebody was like, "Shuffleboard."
And so now we do that with shuffleboard.
Yeah and then on our last tour,
we started throwing axes.
So I come back and I'm like
now, in the same genre,
in the same, we also
call it a bucket of like
guessing using some physical challenge
and let's do that with axes.
Now we haven't done that
yet but we're gonna do it.
I'm just saying we're gonna do it
so if somebody does it before us
or has already done it,
I don't know about it
and we are gonna do it.
It's tough to keep up
with who's done what,
that's for sure, and there's a lot of
like convergent ideation on the internet,
where you end up doing the same thing
just because everyone is
thinking, everyone is,
this is what I'm trying to
articulate in frenish is
that everyone is ideating
in the same landscape,
kind of in the same ways and I think that,
and I don't know if we're
capable of it, let me just say,
I don't know if we're capable of it
and I don't know if you can do
it within GMM and not kill it
but I think the challenge
that we're trying to approach
is how do you level up
the genre as opposed to
just reinventing the wheel
and just making it a little
bit flashier of a wheel.
Yeah, 'cause you look at
That's the conversation.
'Cause you look at Fallon,
how long can Fallon
just have top notch
celebrity guests come in
and put their hands in
things or drink things,
the same stuff that we're doing,
he can probably do it a
lot longer than we have
because it's a television institution.
And as much as I'd like to
think and maybe for some people,
GMM is starting to feel like
an internet institution,
it's like we cannot,
we can't rest on that,
whether it's true of false.
I don't know, it doesn't
matter to me at this point
and you know, what
matters is creating things
that we're excited about
within the context of the show,
if I'm just looking at the show,
and that we also think will
work, and that is a challenge.
I mean, on one stop on the
Bleak Creek Conversations,
we would always answer
questions from the audience
that were tweeted at us and one question,
let's see, 'cause I'm trying to remember.
I actually don't remember the question
but the answer was basically,
why do we want to write a novel?
And we talked about our
passion for storytelling
and once we had the
opportunity then our excitement
to mine our shared
experiences and our friendship
and like pour that into a novel.
So much of it was about story though.
But then the thing in my answer was
there was another side benefit,
something we didn't anticipate,
with saying yes to the huge
project of writing a novel
and that was it really
got us back in touch
with the roots of our friendship.
Um hm.
So yeah, we created that documentary
in order to make the connection
between the novel and our
friendship in order to
not just to sell the book but
honestly that's part of it.
Yeah.
But then it became such
a important project,
just the documentary part, I
think it was so important to us
to reconnect with our
friendship that we wanted
to make sure that not only ticket holders
to the Conversation events but
everyone who wanted to see it
who's a fan of ours could see it
and that's why we put it out
as three episodes of
Good Mythical Morning.
As we're recording this,
we're in the middle of
the second day and we're
already seeing the response.
I don't know how may views
it'll end up getting.
You know, I think Part One
is doing doing pretty well.
Here's the ironic thing, right?
This documentary of us going
back to our childhood homes,
and Part One is literally
visiting the homes we grew up in,
is not taking off as fast as a video
that's just about food, right?
However, there are a lot of people
who are voicing their opinions about it
and saying, "I love seeing
this kind of content from you,
"I love when you guys
get out into the world."
And obviously there is no world
in which we turn Good
Mythical Morning into that
because I think even
if you've never edited
a video in your life, you
probably have some appreciation
for the fact that those documentary,
the three part documentary
was a lot harder
to put together than an episode
of Good Mythical Morning,
like exponentially more
time went into that.
Sure, so that can't become
Good Mythical Morning
and that's not what's on the table.
Seeing the people's response to it
because it literally is taking,
putting into the GMM flow
something that's completely unexpected
and completely outside of the
genre that we've established.
I'm not saying we're gonna
move in that direction,
I'm just saying that it shakes things up
and it gets our minds working
Well, I think,
in a different way.
One thing that we know it already did was,
I hope this happened.
I think that it reminded people
that the reason why Good
Mythical Morning works
is because of the deeply
rooted friendship.
It's not just about,
what are they gonna eat
and gag into a trashcan, ya know?
And I found myself saying
that in answering a question
at the Conversations last week
and then people started applauding.
I mean, we didn't talk
about that with every stop
but I think that it's,
Well the people who've made a decision
to come to a Bleak Creek Conversation,
that's a very particular group of people.
Sure.
And those people are
like, "Guys, I'm on board,
"not just to watch you eat,
"I'm on board because of who
you are and your friendship."
And so we get that.
But it's an interesting dance, right?
Because if you lean completely into that,
we probably wouldn't.
Here's the ironic thing.
Again, now if I could
speak Spanish or French,
I'd be better at saying this
but the ironic part of this
is that because we've chosen
to create Good Mythical Morning
in a certain way that is
designed to kind of go out there
and take advantage of the
way people's online behavior
on the platform of YouTube,
the way the algorithm serves up videos
and the way people click on things,
the titles and the
thumbnails and all that stuff
that goes right into
that point of decision
of somebody clicking on the video.
Because we've done that for
seven years, 16 seasons,
we then have the
privilege to write a book,
make a documentary, get
people to buy the book,
get people to watch the documentary,
put it on a channel where
you've built this momentum
doing all these things.
And finding the balance,
I feel like, is the real,
is what we're trying.
We're trying to find the balance,
that's what we're trying to achieve.
And just to clarify, is it a
balance between two things?
What are those two things
that you're saying?
I'm saying that you
can't just go completely
on one side of the spectrum,
which would be like,
Confessional.
Well, I was gonna go to
the other side first.
Okay.
The I'm just trying to get
you to click on a video,
that's all I want you to do
is to just click on a video
and I don't care whether you
are an existing fan or a new fan.
I just want you to click on a video.
And then you've got the
complete opposite end
of the spectrum is like, I
don't care about the algorithm,
I don't care about the machine,
I don't care about the game.
I just to want to be my
unfiltered, authentic self.
And I don't care about schedule,
I don't care about how often we upload,
I don't care about it
being a reliable thing
that can be there every single day.
It's just this completely authentic,
if I feel like it, I will make a video.
That is a part of YouTube
and there are people
who are successful in that place.
I couldn't make a video
for the past month, guys,
because I've been doing X, Y, and Z.
We don't ever do that.
We say, we probably
shouldn't have made videos
for the past month because
we're doing X, Y, and Z
but we still gave you 20 videos this month
or 40 or whatever the number is.
So yeah I don't know exact,
to bring it full circle back
to self-promotion, right?
Which is where this conversation started.
I do think that whatever
the answers end up being
to these questions and
what is striking a balance
and how does that work.
I will say that I am personally
much more interested in
and excited about that documentary
going out to our audience
and them being able to make
the connection between,
oh, this is the world you guys grew up in.
Like you tweeted, "if you want to know
"why we are who we are",
then watch this.
Making that connection between us
and then the work that we put out, right?
Bleak Creek is a incredibly,
deeply personal expression
of our highest creative aspirations.
Not only is it something
that we feel great about,
that we crafted it, but we
feel great about the fact
that it is so tied to who we are
and I would much rather be
able to do that on our terms.
Being able to take that documentary
and put it in place of
a show where we usually
just sit at a desk and do something,
having the privilege
to be able to do that,
I'm much more excited about that exercise
than I am going on somebody else's show,
wearing the right thing,
saying the right thing,
to get the right audience
excited about the book.
I'm gonna keep doing that.
We're gonna keep doing
traditional promotions
for the things that we need to do
but what am I personally excited about?
I'm excited about the medium
that we have freedom in.
Yeah.
I mean, unfortunately the
real choice before us,
the thing that we're wrestling with,
it's not a choice between do we promote
on other people's podcasts
or do we make our own thing.
Right.
There's not actually a dichotomy there.
We're gonna do both of those.
Well I guess what just
happened in this conversation
was we kinda pulled back the curtain more
on like where our minds are,
you know, with our own content
which again, that's what
we care so much about.
Promotion's always gonna be a part of that
but we might be dressing
a little more elevated
than we would have expected.
Maybe we'll just go, next time
let's just go in long johns.
Yeah, that would be, let's just go in,
Will they let us on?
If the flaps are up.
I don't know what the conclusion
to this conversation is.
Like you said, we've
let you in on a little,
we've opened the flap of
the front of our long johns
and let you into this
intimate conversation
about the creative process.
Way to make 'em feel great about it.
Well, I want 'em to get
out of it, you know?
I don't want 'em to get too,
We're opening the back flap
now, you're gonna exit.
Go right out.
But we got a rec.
It's my rec.
Rec baby, rec baby, one, two, three, four.
All right, fine, you know what?
Why don't I just turn the
rec into self-promotion?
Yeah, that would be appropriate.
Well, I do think since
you've listened this far
on this Ear Biscuit,
maybe you have an appetite
to hear us talk more and more,
so I would recommend those
three podcasts we did.
We're proud of those conversations.
If you're really into,
we talk about the novel
in each of them, of course,
we're promoting that,
but if you're really into horror
and like our thoughts on that.
So horror is a hard word for me to say.
Dead Meat James is a good one.
If you're into just like
Rhett and Link in random,
off the rails mode, the Books On A Subway,
am I getting that right?
Books On The Subway.
And if you want an unfettered,
into uncharted Rhett and
Link conversation territory,
because Pete Holmes loves to talk
about faith and philosophy,
so he gets into it
and brings us along for the ride
so we talk about lots of things
in that two hour conversation
on You Made It Weird so
those are my three recs after all that,
Wow, three recs.
Yeah, I'm freely frickin'
promoting myself.
No, you're promoting three
other people's podcasts.
Yeah, I am but I'm only
promoting us on them.
Right, but maybe they will
get into those worlds,
they'll open up those flaps.
See what's inside those
long johns, ya know?
Pete's got long johns too.
I'm really interested,
I'm really interested on what you thought
about this conversation.
Use #BLEAKCREEK and let us know.
Whenever we talk about what we're thinking
about Good Mythical Morning,
I start to get nervous
because I get nervous that
we're making fans nervous
because I know that
there's so many just like,
hey this is part of my daily routine,
and I don't want there to be any inkling
of anything that threatens that.
And that's not what we were talking about,
We're just choosing,
But I do get nervous.
We're just, you know,
just because mom and dad
are in the kitchen
having a little bit of a,
like they've raised
their voice a little bit,
it doesn't mean they're
getting divorced necessarily.
Right, right.
Okay?
No, I think that we have,
But if they do, it's your fault.
No.
I think that this is an effort, well,
Ear Biscuits has slowly
evolved in itself, right?
And has become a place
that we're just talking,
it's just two buds talking.
In fact, that's probably
the biggest change
that we're gonna make in 2020.
It's gonna be Two Buds Talking,
formerly knows as Ear Biscuits.
That's the first big
announcement that we can make.
No, we're not gonna do that.
No, nothing's gonna change in a way,
nothing's being threatened,
it's just we're letting you in.
We're letting you into the
conversation a little bit.
#BLEAKCREEK, that's your way to engage.
Oh yeah, because we don't know
what the timeline on this is
but we are gonna do an episode
where we do a spoiler-ridden,
not a spoiler-free,
but a spoiler-full discussion of the book
for anyone who has read the book
and so we're gonna keep giving
you some time to do that.
Make notes of your
questions or observations.
Anything, it's not just
gonna be questions.
And if you haven't read the book,
you don't wanna read the
book, I'm hearing that a lot,
well, you can hear the book
Yeah.
on Audible.
More self-promotion.
Yeah, well, we wanna talk about it
and we wanna talk about is as a family.
Kids, come downstairs.
Mom and Dad have something
they want to discuss with you.
It's the book they wrote.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.